[Music]
this is ridiculous
2335 the mombot shuffle that might be
2900 is this is this uh chest bra
is this not chest bra
okay hopefully this isn't just run like
a smurf
okay so this is in english this might be
a monolith no could somebody confirm are
they like
are they streaming so basically they're
playing the anyways we're gonna play
this normally
so we have an english in a slightly
weird a slightly weird setup by white
we're just developing our pieces
now the d4 square is weak how do we
exploit
on the basis of this concept that we've
discussed many times what should be our
next move what should be our ultimate
idea
what should be our ultimate idea we want
to get the knight to d4 how do we do
that
bingo bishop g4 again i must
emphasize at this point we don't want to
rush
giving up the bishop for the night we
want to have this option in our pocket
so that when the time comes we play
um we play bishop takes f39 now here
he's got it5
so what should we do here what comes to
mind and this is a great example of us
not rushing
not rushing with the move um with the
move
knight so yeah we can play knight t4 but
um before we do that let's let's get rid
of this knight it's annoying the hell
out of me
and and then let's play knight t4 to try
to shatter his kingside font structure
does that make sense there is another
perk
of going knight takes d5 what is it what
do we what idea becomes now possible in
the future
now that we've removed the knight from
f6 and which one of these pieces should
we actually end up taking
this is where people are gonna get go
wrong the idea is a five and because
this idea
exists here's what we're gonna do
normally we would take the knight and
keep our knight established on d4 but
because i believe the idea of f5 is so
strong
we're actually going to take the bishop
and now we're going to castle and we're
going to try to ram
f5 through and we're going to try to
apply as much pressure as possible on
this knight
so this is a great example of where
okay so he's gone g4 but he's stopped f5
but he's made
massive weaknesses on the king side
which we're going to try to exploit in
the long term
and by the way f5 is still an idea we
can sack a piece here
but before we do anything we need to
sort of break into the center
uh if we if we let his pawns remain in
the center
we're gonna have a very hard time
getting stuff done
so let's go c6 to break him up a little
bit and potentially we can play d5 and
ultimately
if we can get this pawn off of e4 it's
going to be easier for us to get a 5 in
so black is better here
i think that he did a good thing our
opponent by playing fh3 g4 otherwise it
would have been crushing
but a great position for us let's see if
we can capital queen a2 okay
so that's weird and we're trying he's
trying to discourage us from playing
from playing f5 i get the ultimate idea
and how can we deal with this pin
that's like sounds like a mom-bod
shuffle move that bad shuffle
well we want to prepare d5 right we want
to prepare d5
and um yeah let's go king h8 first let's
unpin ourselves
let's let's let's un-pin ourselves so
that we don't have to worry about
not being able to play f5 okay his
attacks are pawn let's
uh let's defend it rook c8 and get the
rook into the game
okay nothing surprising here and now
let's prepare
d5 how do we prepare e5 who can name
a good move and here's what i want to
hear i want to hear a move that
doesn't sacrifice the health of our
position
in preparing d5 so a move like rookie 8
would not be good
because it would make it harder in the
future to prepare five we want the rook
remaining on f8
in case we have the opportunity to play
f5 so let's go queen e7 this also just
connects the rook
even if we don't go d5 we just connect
the rooks which is good
and um that's just independently good
regardless of what we do so he stops d5
because he's going to take and take c8
uh and we now have to find a way to
somehow twist the knife in
so let's actually go b5 yeah so that's
what i wanted to discourage he goes a4
anyway
let's take it he takes with the queen
and this actually might be a good time
to start sacking everything with f5
because he's gotten his queen away from
the king side
and i actually think that might be a
really interesting try
let's do it let's sacrifice a piece on
f5
his king is like wide open so i feel
like my two rooks in the queen
are going to constitute enough material
to cause him tremendous difficulty in
defense okay but he finds a really nice
idea
so i could take on f3 and probably make
a draw but
how else could we attack the knight
oh but he has a defense there oh this is
not good
one sec let me think hmm
well queen f6 and queen f sound the
problem varus he goes rook a8
the problem there and i missed this idea
this is this is a problem i mean he
found this
very quickly yeah we're gonna have to go
rook f3 here we're gonna have to accept
this end game
we're gonna have to accept this end game
and uh
i don't know who's better i think black
is still better now
he's attacking this so let's go h5
create some look
let's create some left
this rook is undefended alarm bells
alarm bells alarm bells rook is
undefended
king is weak four fork fork fork fork
queen g5
the game is up so we were still better
there because his king was so wide open
and the ultimate goal was to win before
good game
wins the rook and the sacrifice actually
ended up working
although it was close he found a very
nice defensive idea
um no it's not crazy it's just that he
played too fast now the idea of this
line if we go bishop c5
what idea does white have this is
hilarious because we just talked about
this in the previous game
so who can apply the same idea to a
different position
what do you look for when there's a
knight on c6 and bishop on c5
exactly this is actually the theoretical
line and black is it's not that black is
in trouble
but white can get a better position here
which is why bishop b4 is considered to
be the best move
so now everything we did here should be
very obvious knight d4
and this is where i made the judgment
call i was like okay we want to play f5
and uh it would be it would be less
effective to play f5 if we if we were to
do this
because one of the one of the benefits
of f5
is that we increase the pressure on the
knight on f3
and it it's important to keep the knight
there it's important to keep the pin
and we castle because we want to
recapture on f5 with the rook
to enhance the pressure on the knight
okay
so he chases us away but he does it at
the cost of creating weaknesses now we
open up the center
we go king h8 to unpin ourselves
queen e7 to connect the rooks and
prepare d5 b5 to stop a4
now why didn't i consider h5 so a lot of
people wanted me
at some point to play the move h5 and
the reason that i didn't play it is i
was afraid that it would create more
harm than good
right the good that it would create is
that it would soften up his king side
the harm that it would create is that it
weakens my own king's side and this is a
great example of applying a concept i
talked about earlier which is does he
have
enough pieces on the king side to
exploit this weakness and the answer is
actually yes
because what idea does white have that
he can now apply
and he can start piling up on a weakness
that has just been created by playing h5
hg
rook h1 yeah and guess what that queen
ain't too far away from h3
and then he's gonna be threatening
checkmate and attacking this pawn isn't
such a big deal why can't just defend it
by moving the knight out of the way
so so this was a judgment call i didn't
do any calculation to determine this
it was just something i decided on the
basis of these observations that's all
that i was thinking
and this is the critical moment now i
was worried that if i did not go f5
he would basically put pressure on the
pawn and my initiative was going to
evaporate
so something like this could be nasty
and i just felt like my
chances to get stuff done the king side
were rapidly evaporating so that's why i
thought okay i need to do something
right now and that's why i played f5
now part of the reason i thought this
was a good time for f5 is that his queen
is kind of out of the game it's out of
the defense so
it's as good of a time as any because
his knight is his only piece
guarding the king this may be unsound
but i actually don't see exactly how
white can defend
easily if he goes rook c6 i'm just gonna
go rook at fate
right i don't really care about him
taking the pawn what i want to do is
pile up on the f file
there's some cool lines here but i
actually have to go in like
three minutes so i'm going to just
talk about one more one more moment
which is like here
why didn't i pile up on the knight even
further and the reason was the move rook
a8
what does this accomplish well if we
take the knight then he cuts the legs
off with brook takes f8
and then queen takes f3 right if we
take the rook and obviously he forces
the queen trait actually he can even win
the queen with rook c8
so um we kind of have to take now or
never
what happens now is that we have a queen
for two rooks
uh four pawns each his pawns are super
weak he does have a passport
he should have gone rook b1 to protect
it but instead he went for this weird
idea
of shifting his king away he just forgot
about this fork i think he didn't
realize that his rooks were unprotected
and when you have two rooks against the
queen one of the top pieces of advice i
have is to keep your rooks
defending each other queens are
incredibly good at forcing
forks when you keep your rooks defending
each other it reduces the possibility of
forks in addition
rook b1 would defend the b4 pawn and
defend its neighbor on c1 so there would
have been no forks i think this is a
draw
i basically probably would have had to
force a perpetual black has ways to play
for a win here
but i don't think that black is
substantively better
he is not 2900 i don't know what people
are talking about
so in any case guys i hope this game
makes sense there's more to talk about
but i have to run
there should be six this is all fury now
we bring our bishop out we try to get
rid of this knight
and now thank you both thing we have
that trap and this time he plays
correctly the last time he played king
h2
and he he blunted this trap this is
actually the best move
now we have one more piece that we need
to bring into the game what should we do
what uh what piece do we need to bring
into the game which currently is not
doing anything
and that's a very simple way of doing
that of course we need to bring the rook
we need to put it on the eight because
we've vacated that square by the other
rook
yeah so d would be a little less
effective it would just be sort of
staring at the pawn
and basically that pawn on e4 is what
we're trying to target here right we are
kind of
centering our forces okay that is a very
strange move
oh that is actually not a strange move
he's so dc he wants to play f4
and then he wants to play e5 and drive
in that wedge into my position thank you
tyler mandel gifting to vitorash
via trash let me think about this for a
second
okay so what do we want to do here how
can we react to a move like this
well there's many things we can do we
don't actually have to take
uh but one thing that i want to show you
guys is a positional peace sacrifice we
are going to take
and here's what we're going to do what
we're going to do
let's see if he plays f4 he does
we're going to sacrifice a piece and
here's how we're going to do it
we're going to move the knife back to d7
that should be logical and after e5
how are we going to i assume he's going
to play e5 how are we going to sacrifice
a piece what are we going to do
to break open the position we're going
to do it for three pawns
and we're going to do it because his
king is a lot weaker than mine
so it should make sense to you guys
logically speaking
that opening up the position will allow
us to attack okay so we have three fonts
for the piece
let's take stock for a second what do we
need to do what we need to do
is we need to basically get our pieces
to the king side
first of all let's take the rook and
let's let's really reduce that
squeegen a5 catches my eye because it's
it's sort of it's
uh it's under under fire of the bishop
can we put the queen on a square
where it's at least making contact with
something on the king's side
well we can put it on c7 yeah it's
making contact with the pawn
and i want to make it clear that the
queen can be very strong on squares like
these because it's kind of hidden by my
own pawns
so it can't be targeted by my opponent
and i can combine it with a move like
knight h5
and start pressuring the pawn right
that's kind of what i'm trying to do
here no secret
okay so he's driving his pawns in um
knight h5 maybe he's got bishop
uh chasing it away so let's actually go
h5 and let's see if we can run r ram
this pawn to h4 potentially
okay now we need to defend the c5 pawn
he's just attacked it
uh so i see he wants to probably go a5
that's probably what he wants to do and
then what we're going to do
what we're going to do why did we play
h5 what is the logical follow-up
to that move okay he doesn't do it he
actually is playing this game extremely
well
now h4 here would be
logical but then he just played g4 so
this knight on f6
can be improved where can we ultimately
where can we
guide this night where can we maneuver
it well he's got an extra piece for
three pawns so we can maneuver it to e5
that's a central square
we can maneuver the knight to e5 and
that would just that would chase the
queen away
and that would open up the bishop
slightly for now so let's see where he
goes we so
i would say the position is unclear i
don't think we're worse i don't think
black is better
he's been playing this tremendously so
far but this is where a lot of people go
wrong like this is an unbalanced
position
any mistake could cost either side the
game basically
okay i don't think white is clearly
better i would respectfully disagree
with that i think it's unclear
okay so he goes here
and uh he pins our knights of the queen
pins are knights of the queen
okay what should we do here who can come
up with an idea
so g5 is good g5 distracts the queen
yeah and he plays it super well in
response
and now what we should do is let's bring
our queen into d7
to support the rogue so that the knight
can then move
okay we're going queen d7 it goes rook
d1 that's oh i actually missed that move
yeah we have to go to e7 actually that's
what we should have done initially
should have gone to e7 um i i forgot
that he had this move
um yeah very sharp position nonetheless
so what is going to be our planning our
plan is going to be twofold
and we still want to target blacks
white's king
and sometimes in order to target your
opponent's king what you have to do is
create
stronghold squares for your piece okay
bishop p2
that's another insane very good move hmm
yeah this is getting very monga s so
let's go g4 let's let's just explode the
king side
yeah he's playing very good but we're
going we're gonna sacrifice upon here
in order to open up some avenues okay
which he doesn't take
he instead piles up on the square he
wants to checkmate us
well i've got to take we can't let him
check meta so let's take the bishop
now let's um well let's activate our
queen
and let's put it on let's put it on f6
potentially targeting the f3 square
that's what i'm doing um
so oh this is another a really good move
one sec
okay i'll go rook d and i'll attack his
queen queen h7 is not checkmate because
we have this fade square sorry i'm not
like
explaining as vocally as normally but
okay
okay now we're gonna get the rook in
we're gonna get the rook involved we're
gonna attack the bishop
and now um hmm
he's not cheating relax now we're gonna
go
check we're gonna force the queen tray
and at the end of the queen trade what
are we gonna do we're gonna take the
pawn
and now what happens we have all of
these pawns
and we need to push them because they
are passed but we need we need to push
them very strategically
what we first need to do is win this
spot if we win that pawn
then we will be able to start pushing
the other pawns more easily because this
is like an obstruction
so let's capture it and then let's start
pushing the c pawn and let's see who's
first
okay first we're gonna bring our king
out oh god i just made a big mistake i
i allowed bishop f4 which i missed oh
god this is bad for me this might be my
first loss actually
let me focus for a second guys
let me just focus here and then i'll
explain the stuff at the end
yeah this guy's playing the game the
game of his life but
he's totally legit 100
um and it's not easy to bring me down so
i think i'll be fine
but we'll see
okay
it's another amazing one by the way
jesus
i can do this though
oh my god i'm going to the fork and he
doesn't see it oh my god
oh that was close okay i'm going to the
fork there at some point
you are the fastest improving chess
player he says
lmao oh okay i can't talk
on this account that was that was an
incredible game of my opponent he played
like a gm
i have to give him full compliment
um that was incredible play
okay he says you're the fastest
improving chess player i don't know if
he knows this is a speedrun account okay
so there's a lot to explain guys i'm
sorry
and this is going to happen
progressively and and i get
it one sec i think he was joking
um the accuracy is going to be very low
because of the last part of the game
thank you pat adam for the prime damn
i'm i'm playing well guys
84.3 for him 92.5 for me
um so it's like high quality chess but
uh but i there was clothes there was a
moment when i thought it was
it was losing okay so if i had lost that
game there would be no shame
now let's talk through some of the key
moments here because
a lot went on and i want to explain some
of the things that i didn't fully flesh
out during the game
okay so this line we repeated literally
move for move
and i've had this over the board now
basically
does anybody remember if white goes a3
and even anatoly carpal fell into this
what is the trap that i had illustrated
previously does anybody remember
there is a very very beautiful idea that
black has here
and the way you see this is the bishop
is not on its fiance square i've
explained that previously which means
that the square on f3
is vulnerable to a potential fork which
means we have to distract the queen but
we can't distract the queen
yet we first distract the knight now we
distract the queen
then we fork the queen and the king we
take the queen
and you might be like wait a second now
white gets two pieces for a rook white
is fly no he's not the knight is now
hanging
and if the knight goes out to g5 and
counter attacks the rook then we can
counter attack
white's rook at the end of the day
black's gonna be up a lot of material
so is the thing that happens after a3 it
happens even after f4 you can take on e4
anyway
and if white takes the other knight then
you take on g3
and this is where my idea of a peace set
came from this is actually theory
and black's got a very strong attack
against the exposed king
and this should make sense to people
thank you hello desk sorry hell desk
gifting to beer fish appreciate the
support okay so this makes sense to
people so king g2
is the best move according to theory
because
uh he defends the f3 square so this
obviously will not work now
uh you will no longer have a fork on f3
you'll simply blunder the knight there
and and that's prophylaxis so rook a8
makes sense
and now c5 is a move i'm not familiar
with according to the computer
um let's see what according to the
computer this is a very good move
and uh this move might actually throw
this line
so what what should i have done here i
should have actually moved my knight
away first probably
so that c5 wouldn't be a thing so the
idea of c5 as you guys
already understand i think is that
okay he's attacking the pawn so i can't
ignore this if i push d5
good night man then we blunder the pawn
right and by the way if we
if we pin the queen to the knight he can
take on f6 that is check
okay so no problem i take now he goes f4
he attacks tonight
this is like an undermining move right
because now he's got the possibility of
going e5
because the pawn is no longer on d6 this
is a very unpleasant situation
because he attacks the knight if i move
my knight away then queen takes d7
happens and he wins the other night uh
you might look at this for a second and
say well no problem you can go knight to
d5
but guess what he takes twice and now
look at the position very carefully
bishop on g7 is locked out by white's
poncho that's why pawn chains can be so
scary
knight on d7 is hanging pawn on c5 is
weak pawn on b7 is hanging
do you guys see how bad this is i mean
it's just it's a nasty position
this is just visually a nasty position
and so i made the decision the executive
decision and this is my biggest advice
perhaps from this game
when things are going wrong like this
you want to find a way as
some chess authors call it to change the
course of the game or change the trend
of the game
sometimes the game is moving in the
wrong direction and sometimes it might
very well be the case that the computer
actually recommends knight to fight
maybe that's
marginally speaking the best move but
it's a lot more uncomfortable for your
opponent
if you do something like sack the night
because that basically changes the
landscape it forces him to adapt
and guess what it's actually not that
bad so you want to make sure that this
way that you're choosing of
changing the course of the game is
actually not terrible
uh and this isn't because we get three
pawns for the piece
and we weaken this king but i think you
guys see what i'm saying
i am not a millionaire now so we take
twice he goes bishop d2 we take the
rogue
and now queen c7 should make sense to
people we are moving the queen
out of the range of the bishop queen c7
okay a4 a4 is a very good move uh what
is the purpose of this move
wha wha like what exactly is he
accomplishing here which is actually
very instructive i'm going to take a sip
of the [ __ ]
i put a lot of hot sauce in it too a lot
okay 95 is the best move nice
[Music]
so what he's really doing no he's not
prevented preparing the rook lifts
because
the rook lift is pretty it's pretty
far-fetched because he's got a knight
here
what he's basically doing is uh
preventing my pawns from pushing forward
he's
reducing the mobility of my pawns
and he's doing that by preventing d5 and
eventually he can push his pawn to a5
and what that does is a very interesting
situation
i played h5 to potentially go to h4 and
create weaknesses on his king
um let's say that he would have played
a5 the problem here
is if i ever push the b pawn what does
white do in this situation and what does
white accomplish as a consequence of
doing that
and this is a situation you guys should
sort of file into your mental rolodex
so he takes on poisson and what he gains
is the eighth file and he can use the
save file you can put his queen there he
reduces my upon majority
and and he can infiltrate down that a
file if he wants to so
it's a very hard situation to get out of
if you're black but he decided to go
bishop f2
um okay so i went b6 to defend the pawn
now we got our knight to a slightly
better square
and here he did he he played extremely
well so queen f4 is nice
g5 for a second i thought it wins the
piece but it doesn't helldesk thank you
for the gift to dark dota 94
because he's got queen e4 and if we
unpack the situation the knight cannot
move because
the rook is pinned so i defended the
rook so that the knight can move
but he goes rook d1 and he attacks my
queen forcing him to move again
okay so i move it and he goes bishop
back to e2 very nice move
how does he find this move the moment i
played g5
my opponent was like ah this pawn on h5
is not weak and i tell you guys to do
this all the time
when a pawn is pushed on a particularly
important side of the board you should
understand for like 5-10 seconds okay
what weaknesses are created
so the pawn in h5 is now weak it's not
defensible by any other pawns
and so he drops his bishop back to
attack it and
remember that i have sacrificed a piece
so i can't just willy-nilly give up
pawns which i kind of did because i had
to
so if he takes on g5 i just take his
bishop remember that the queen is
defending the bishop
so if he takes on g5 i simply take the
bishop
so that is a very classy move which
hopefully everybody understands by now
i played g4 the reason that i did that
was i figured if i'm not already giving
up a pawn
and there's literally no way to defend
this one i figured i might
i might as well induce some marginal
weaknesses in his position so i thought
i might as well get rid of his h1
so that his king becomes a little bit
weaker and i think there was no reason
for my opponent not to take the pawn i
think he bought my bluff
which was also part of why i played it i
this is just like bluff because black is
nothing
black is much much worse slash lost and
bishop v2 was a crusher so
bishop back to d3 gives me a bit of a
respite because now i take on d3
i still have three pawns for the piece i
can centralize my queen and stuff
and this is where i i was like very much
on the nice
so a lot of people would see this move
and think ah you know this is just
crushing
but the reality is the bishop on g7 one
of the perks of putting it there
is h7 is not going to be checkmate
you're just going to be able to slide
your king to f8
and mayonnaise master gifting to raffle
is a lot thank you guys
so does that make sense that's why i
allowed myself this move he does give a
check
but then he quickly realized that i
actually have a bigger threat than he
just played on the board which is queen
f3 check that's why he brings his queen
back i go rook t2
this is where i made a very very
important decision the decision i made
here
is to trade queens yeah 24 i
hallucinated that he has checkmate for
some reason i forgot that his rook
is not on e1 i thought this was mate but
obviously it's not so i saw this move
and forgot about it this would have been
super strong
instead i basically give up a pawn in
order to get into an end game why did i
do that
so the reason i did that is in the same
speed it's a move in the same spirit
as knight takes e5 uh he is ready
he is geared up to attack and by trading
queens i'm forcing him to adapt to a new
type of situation and also objectively
look at my pawn mass
i judged that these pawns would
essentially be unstoppable
i was kind of wrong because he played
this extremely well
what he basically does is he gives up
the pawn but he goes for peace activity
look at how he activates his king
he brings his rook to an open file very
instructive play bishop
to an open diagonal king out king out to
f5 i mean
now i'm in huge trouble i had to find
this really important move rook a3
the idea of this move is if he takes on
f6 what happens who can tell me what the
idea of
three is yeah no one understands the
algorithm
i think most of my viewers are a lot of
my viewers are subs now so
that's a good thing so yeah rook f3 at
the end so basically i'm repositioning
my rook
to god have three win the night that is
a defensive idea
that i found amen
and basically what happens now is we get
this pawn race
the pawn race comes down to some tactics
and here i could have forced to draw but
i found this idea it takes a bit should
be two
amazing position i'm down a rook but he
can't stop my promotion
so he tries to distract me by giving me
this check
and now i go king f8 i'm not sure if
this actually works i'm gonna check the
computer here
oh oh my god white is winning
so i could have made a draw i could have
made a draw with king g7 white is
winning with a beautiful idea
very hard to find yeah so king h6
now the reason okay i think we we know
your answer is in cosa
i think the reason this is hard to see
is because
we allow promotion and even though black
is now up to pawns
and it seems like we're out of the woods
white goes king h7 that's the whole idea
and g7 is unstoppable this idea is
literally unstoppable white makes a
queen wait what's the game
so i mean for finding this in time
pressure it is so hard particularly
because you have to refrain
from giving a discovered check which is
incredible but what i did
i maneuvered my king to ga and by the
narrowest of threads
i'm able to avoid checkmate and white is
already losing here because if he gives
a check on f6
the bishop is multitasking because it's
a
it's supporting the promotion square but
b it's defending this square otherwise
it would be checkmate obviously
all right so at this point i promote the
queen
this is still very tricky but i made a
queen or they actually blundered a fork
that's kind of funny i didn't expect
king c8 i expected king c7
then i thought i was going to give a
check but he went king c8 and he could
have
made a draw here with 97 so i got very
lucky here this could have easily been
my first loss
it could have also easily been my first
try and we got another gifted sub from
helldesk
to ships at dark but hopefully the
explanations make sense this was a
pretty complex game
um and and my opponent played extremely
well so big big kudos to
vanya hargreaves
the speed run is officially over my head
but okay i want to push back on that
perceptus what like what part exactly
if i may ask uh was like you feel like
over your head like what explanation do
you feel like was
or was it sort of a general thing but
was if there's something specific that i
can clarify or explain better
um i i want to do that and i mean it
i mean i know that this game is
complicated i'm under no illusions
um and i don't expect beginners to
follow everything i do and say
right but that's a limited mentality
right because after the game
i i explain everything very slowly i i'm
not expecting people to follow
everything during the game but after the
game i'm really trying to break things
down in a way that most people will
understand
okay all of it was over my head
uh even the explanations
okay
yeah there is a ton to unpack i and and
remember to ask specific questions like
um i'm trying to like group things into
concepts right so for example in the
opening
right uh the way that i think you guys
should think about this if you're rated
700 800 how should you try to understand
these games
you should try to categorize the moves
rather than trying to understand each
move on a granular level
you should try to yeah so changing the
course of the game so you should try to
understand what a move accomplishes on a
broad level
for example um for example
uh a move like 95 okay like what does
this move accomplish
like what what is the purpose of this
move
and what is the purpose of this move
because all of these moves belong to the
same exact category this move
and even this move all of these moves
have been played with the same intention
in mind it's not outpost why
it's it's all about the meta patterns
um activating your pieces you're simply
completing your development in a way
that is geared toward exploiting the
main weaknesses in your opponent's
position because white
has two main weaknesses here it is his
central pawns
right his central pawns are the things
that we want to attack here
so not only do we position our pieces on
better squares and sort of
develop visually we put them on squares
where they are
better at applying pressure at white's
main weaknesses
okay so then
the move knight takes e5 right how do we
categorize this move this is a changing
the course of the game move
so the last couple moves white has been
putting pressure on me
and um you know i have to
move my knight i mean anybody should see
that my knight is being attacked
so knight e5 i explained i explained why
this is bad
and the reason this is bad is because of
several factors that coalesce together
and make black's position very nasty the
first thing is
there is simply a lot of hanging [ __ ]
here right
and you guys should just see that right
the knight is hanging
knight takes a queen takes b7 and if the
knight moves
then then you give up this pawn because
the bishop defends the queen
then there is a set of more positional
factors
so non-concrete observations nothing
that relates to a specific thing that is
hanging
but rather if you look at this bishop
guys if you look at this bishop
what can you tell me about this bishop
is it a good bishop is it a bad bishop
and why
so i'll explain that is where so queen
c7 would protect everything
in the immediacy but the bishop is
obviously bad
right it's terrible it's blocked by the
pawns and that's why i mention the pawn
shape pawn chains are really good at
blocking off certain pieces
now queen c7 defends against the
immediate threats
but as i have explained black's position
isn't bad
only because there's hanging stuff it's
bad because there's a lot of
long-term weaknesses and so one thing
that white can do here is go rook a to
d1
attacking the knight he can also go what
is another way of attacking the knight
here
what is the other way here of attacking
the knight
yeah the bishop is is just not doing
anything it's staring at the pawn
so there's also bishop b5 right and this
sets a pin
so that is where intuition comes in when
i look at this position
i don't break everything down to these
separate assumptions that's what i do as
a teacher to help people understand
and i don't expect people to do that but
when you do this consistently over the
course of many years
with many positions you train your brain
to immediately
understand the important factors in the
position so i see this like quickly as
okay the bishop is bad
stuff's hanging queen is super active
and
these factors they come together to make
the evaluation what it is
so well rookie the rook on e1 is sort of
supervising that e pawn so this rook is
not doing anything this rook is closer
to the center you want both rooks closer
to the center
and um and that's basically the logic
um the other thing i want to make clear
here is that
you know even at this level things
really can be broken down to these
similarities the game has become more
complicated and what does complicated
mean in the context of chess what it
really means in my opinion
is there's more imbalances right the
positions are less symmetrical
there's more positions where there's a
ton to unpack like there is here
and a lot more hinges on calculation
like we both see this line
so i decide to sacrifice a piece in
order to take the game into a different
direction that's what it means to change
the course of the game
let me give you a drastic example which
i think will help people understand the
concept of changing the course of the
game this is a very famous game
and one of the craziest examples i have
ever seen
of changing the course of the game that
occurred at a grand master level
prepare to get shocked right here and by
the way i really appreciate them people
are honest with me about like
you know certain things they don't
understand i i'm truly passionate about
helping people understand this stuff
so let me let me set up my chest spaces
so this is actually going to blow your
mind
and it'll take it'll take me some
explaining to explain to you guys why
the position is
lost but i will i will manage to do that
i think so
that's what you guys have decided to
play is a game that is uh
very tricky okay so actually oh
so i've been setting this up all along
yeah so basically you guys can see
that this is a game between yaburback
and spassky boris spassky of course
world champion
was 19 when this game was played and
in this position average is the oldest
living g up currently
in this position white is completely
winning
white is completely winning why is that
why why is white computer let's flip the
board there's several things to notice
here
the first is look at this piece of crap
right here on g7
look at this piece of crap on g7 it's
literally doing absolutely nothing
but that's not even the most important
thing the fact that black is super
passive
look at the h file very very carefully
you guys see that there is a pawn on h5
this pawn on h5 could capture the pawn
on g6
that opens up the h file and white can
use this hval to deliver checkmate very
very quickly
so let's let's drop a quick example
let's say black develops this knight
okay
this should be reasonable to everybody
we're just developing our knight
okay white takes on g6 we open the h
file
how does white attack this pawn what is
a specific way
in which white could attack the g6 pawn
there's many plans here that win the
game
but i want to give you guys a specific
example of how quickly
things could go bad so this attacks the
pawn
it also opens up a little avenue for the
queen to come out to g4 so let's say
black defends it with his king
black says i'm getting the king out of
there and simultaneously i'm going to
defend the pawn now white has a small
small tactic
that leads basically either to checkmate
or to total devastation
find it
yeah knight g6 is correct
sacrifice checkmate that's it
now black can defend this slightly more
resiliently but he's not going to be
able to stop what
from piling up on the h file and
ultimately delivering some sort of a
checkmate down the hvac
that again i hope is clear to everybody
so spassky was like man i am completely
lost
i'm completely lost and i have to do
something right now
to radically uh change
the way that the game is going and he
plays a move that's one of my favorite
moves ever played
because this move is so absurd it is
completely losing
it doesn't objectively do anything to
save the position
but it shocks the opponent so much that
avermax started to play
absolutely horribly as a consequence of
this move
now you guys are coming close when you
say knight takes d5 but knight takes d5
actually just make thing around this
guy's a gm he's not going to like
flip out at knight takes d5 actually
we've had one
one guy see it which is blind score yeah
knight c6
rn's thing for the prime knight c6
so the knight is going to d4 um so white
has to take it
literally just giving up a full piece
for
minimal compensation minimal there is
however some compensation so what has
been created as a result
first of all white center has been
removed
now if we look at this knight for a
second where can this knight travel yeah
so a lot of you guys are noticing that
the knight can go
out to d4 the other thing is
uh black has this big pawn center and
eventually he could break through with
d5
now these are things that do not
compensate in the least
for the fact that white has an extra
piece white still has that h-file attack
and this is completely losing but if you
watch what happens
spassky actually starts to capitalize on
these things
so aberbach actually does the stuff that
i mentioned
and spassky guess what he gets his
knight to d4 okay
and somewhere around this point
everybody started to play very badly
now he goes queen f7 and all of a sudden
it turns out that white's h-file attack
doesn't lead to clear checkmate in the
meantime spassky
actually begins to attack and and ever
back as winnie spassky takes another
pawn
and then things get really chaotic
things get complicated
avromac was winning with this move but
um this is not that easy to see
so there's actually a really sexy idea
here that this involves so rookie shape
was winning
why because after bishop takes h8 rook
takes a straight
this is a pin king has to describe
skewer king has to move
rook takes v8 it actually looks like
black is a winning move
it actually looks like black is winning
here because you can take the knight
you'll still be down a piece
but black can do what black can play no
knight c2 is not checkmate because of
king d2
but you're thinking in the right
direction now this move would be
checkmate
but there's a queen on g4 that would
take e2 so what you can do
is play f3 intercepting
the queen's control over the square and
the point is
if white goes king d2 and tries to
evacuate we give a check
and we give the checkmate using the
knight on d2 white has a defense
white is an amazing defensive idea here
i'll let you guys
think about it so i can finish off that
phone but
white actually can defend against this
checkmate
and this is really tricky so i'm not
really expecting
everybody to see it and this is
something i would maybe miss
it's a two-move idea
but you go night at four sacking the
night
and after e takes f4 so bishop takes d4
is is not necessarily the best you can
play queen takes f3
immediately and because of the pin
the knight cannot move this would
actually be checkmate were it not for
the pin
e2 is protected and on the next move you
can eliminate the knight and whites
or blacks attack fizzles out the knight
of four is a very pretty move
that exploits this latent pin here right
you don't think this matters but it
actually does
so quite quite a beautiful defensive
idea
and um that's kind of the point of this
whole thing
so basically my voice just got there but
averbach goes bishop d4
and and eventually they get into this
end game and and spassky starts pushing
his pawns
and look at look at how many pawns black
has in the center so basically the game
goes on and on and on
and the game actually ends in a draw the
hilarious thing is spassky was actually
winning at some point
things get chaotic spassky was actually
winning at some point
and you can see how much chaos there is
on the board he wins in exchange that
aberbach blunders and then aberbach is
the one who has to save the draw
which he does and probably but basically
that was
one of the most famous applications of
this concept
um and i hope that it makes a little bit
more sense now like when you're
completely losing
and you feel like your opponent is just
going to steamroll you you got to find a
move that has some sort of shock value
but more importantly it has to be a move
that could plausibly turn the game
around
blundering your queen has shock value
but it's just going to accelerate your
defeat that's where people misunderstand
this i'm not suggesting anybody give up
your rook for
free or give up your queen for free you
got to find a move that actually does
have an idea as this move did right
you actually gained something the bow
test gambit is not going to help
it has to be something that creates
actual chances at the same time
it can be something which whose
psychological value
does outweigh its objective what about a
rookie jacob 99 thank you for the pride
okay back to the speedrun